we were just talking to somebody today
about doers versus dreamers so what do
you think it was that push you to
finally start writing it down uh well I
mean by that time I was already hooked I
mean first short you know the weight
that was it and I realized that was the
path I don't think from that point on I
could write anything and not see it all
the way through so now I take every
project as it comes but I knew this was
one I was going to come back and revisit
it was just about the timing of it but
uh when I thought about it it turned out
to be the perfect project because um you
know because of my stage of filmmaking
where I am I don't have a huge budget or
anything like that so what I did was I
went to the California Film Commission
and I I learned one valuable thing from
that that they don't charge extra
location fees to use california state
property you still have you know your
usual california state fees you have to
pay certain you know permit fees and
things like that but there's no
additional charges which makes those
locations a little bit cheaper than
others so i went to the California film
the Commission and I scouted my
locations for the film before I wrote I
wrote it that's what yeah so then I
basically went through and said okay I
want to shoot here and I checked all the
locations so all the locations that I
had an available access to that was
within a budget that I could get and
then I wrote the story so I think that's
enabled me to keep the budget really low
that's why I think I can shoot it for a
hundred-thousand-dollar micro budget and
I and I still think I can produce a
high-quality image
you